[Music]
and asleep on the job news never have I
ever submitted by ling-ling 24 hours
type an American Airlines baggage
handler fell asleep in the cargo hold of
a plane and was stuck for the duration
of the flight [ __ ] nightmare
everything you can't breathe that's what
I'm thinking freezes oh my god II was
supposed to be in there right he's
supposed to put the luggage in I'd be
opening up people's suitcases trying to
get the oxygen out does that would that
even work did he end up
he's like a now I'm in the Caymans Japan
is Kansas City to Chicago oh yeah not
that crazy so the plane took off at 552
a.m. and this worker admitted that he
was at work intoxicated and he fell
asleep luckily though he was unharmed
because they do pressurize that part of
the cargo thank God
yes [ __ ] they also keep it from
60 to 70 degrees oh damn because
sometimes they'll put live animals down
so that's the reason why he was so lucky
they were like what the hell like why
would you be there and then they were
saying that I guess there's like a
different compartments because in the
compartment he fell asleep and there
were no bags put in until they landed
then that's when they realized he was in
there because he still knocked out I
don't know if he was still knocked out
but they did have like the FBI like
everyone investigating this because it's
like aviation security so it was pretty
it was a big deal god damn it yeah you
know this guy's gone because TIFF
started telling a storm we were all like
what happened like how did this happen
yeah you know what's even crazier it's
not the first time this has happened
people fall asleep back there all the
time
Wow was he young it said he was drunk 23
oh yeah yeah yeah my man came to work
wasted he was like he's just gonna take
us along now
do you think he's like oh man so [ __ ]
up the road it's like the wounds moving
man
annoying like about two hours or less
than two hours that's not bad at all Oh
Kansas City oh oh you started you family
in that Chicago now or what yeah we flew
him back to Kansas City dead cargo bay
still you don't deserve a seat mr. I'm
more so concerned with how calm it seems
like he is about this like the store
comes office so he just got on snapchat
was like bro you guys aren't gonna
believe this it goes my off chills [ __ ]
exactly my black ass would be in there
like wow you know thought I'd be on
every news station like I was terrified
I was scared I called my mom as soon as
I got off the plane like I would not
would y'all not be freaking out what
they're saying like you woke up in
Chicago they were saying that the most
you could feel like is the
claustrophobia
but other than that like they're fine I
mean he didn't wake up like he literally
woke up in Chicago you didn't get any
fear he's woke up you just in a
different place [ __ ] ever he's probably
really comfortable Erica's in the
beginning I was imagining he's hugging
like one of the things that holds tires
by the landing it stays like for two
hours just like that Mission Impossible
movie dude oh I never realized how
concerned I feel for Tom Cruise's
well-being actually really like this guy
I think cuz cuz he's clinging to the
edge of that thing and they actually
shot that [ __ ] and like honestly holding
my breath with that dude I was like god
dammit
wait what thing he was hanging on the
end on the side of a c-130 aircraft and
they fully took off within he like was
hanging on the whole time and it was
really him ozium it was really him my
god that's like amazing grip string they
had him harness to it there's probably
some security but it's doing that [ __ ]
it's crazy that's some Scientology [ __ ]
he's just looking for the next thrill
because like he joined the show actually
this is the second time I've mentioned
that Church and I won't bring it up
again
wait why with all that I know I'm just
saying I mentioned it before what are
they gonna do come after you
wait
do that important they're gonna watch
this are you trying to be that dress no
okay what you're fine
oh oh they only show you if you're an
actor I just keep CIA all these like
Scientology like churches are like
Christian Science reading library and
I'm like what is that
Scientology wait but like what do you
all do it in there you know what I get
offended when I walk by a Scientology
building and they don't pass me anything
yeah that's why that highly offensive
well yeah well they look at you or
they're like oh he's not looking for
answers he's looking for drugs or
something
he looks like he has the answers so I'll
random that you say that so like the
other day I got a piece of mail from the
Church of Scientology and it was like a
handwritten liked out the envelope was
like handwritten blah blah but it was to
an actor and I don't know what his I
just looked it up and like he's an actor
on agents of the shield oh yeah right
and it was delivered to my address he
was like I don't know this game what's
his name I don't remember him personally
I would know what if I saw it but like
yeah we're in the letter and written
what a personal touch right it was it
was a literally I can't and it was like
the Actors Guild of Scientology who odd
ages of shield is in Scientology I need
to know I know what he looks like - but
yeah yeah yeah Hardy dream what does it
matter if he's 100 he's a dream also
what if y'all out me it clearly they
know where I live apartment and
everything oh that's the least of your
problems of Scientology bro thank you
tell your address oh my god girl I guess
we know we're home if you live yeah I
think yeah come come to my place you're
not gonna really you can find me through
all the [ __ ] plants in my house and
good luck what that got me is like we
destroyed all your plans
oh no instead of destroying your plans
they've just gift you more grasshoppers
that's good that be so funny you're like
if you dare touch my grasshopper I'll go
crazy I won't
[Music]
I'm like now you've done it is that
right you old a grasshopper like this
smaller smaller sorry for those who
don't know I have a pet grasshopper
named dirty really I was just picture
the only grasshopper I could think of
was the grasshopper from Mulan so that's
the one I was picking that [ __ ]
grasshopper by boy it's like this is
[ __ ] big I would say that our
grasshopper is like thirty percent less
racist looking but it's it's close so it
looks laces well no the Mulan
grasshoppers like a little Asian oh
maybe that's one yeah that's good it's
[ __ ] hilarious - and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah back to this baggage handler
calling asleep in the cargo area they
were saying this is one baggage handler
back in 2015 the pilots had to turn
around like the flight cuz it was from
Seattle to LA after they heard a whole
bunch of banging yeah that would be me
no like can you imagine being it's like
the last row of a plane and you just
hear like yeah
yeah and like banging on I'd be like I
need some assistance so what happened
they landed that plane immediate well
they turn around cuz there shortly after
takeoff oh oh so you never made it a
shot down oh no no we're talking about
the different one different King guy
from a telly
yeah they ended up saying Seattle yeah
but that's scary good thing to keep it
heated and pressurized over else that
guy wouldn't stop taking your job for
granted yeah but like how would y'all
feel if you were on a flight going
somewhere you didn't really want to take
this fight in the first place and I like
attention passengers it appears that we
have an employee and the cargo we may
have to make an emergency landing is
everyone okay if we're making an
emergency landing and delays me from
getting to a beach somewhere I'm pissed
yeah only a beach well yeah I'm going
home I'm piling them what if the
passengers got the option left you guys
wanna land and let them out or do we
just keep going on destiny we should get
to vote
I think so yeah I did curious with it
would be like 80 seconds like yeah
there'd be like it's fine
he chose this he chose the side he knew
what happened when he took a little nap
in there and he's gonna be fine that's
like the boob grabber dude you guys here
put the boob grab okay no so he's on a
flight and he was like I guess he'd like
reached over and grabbed some lazy boob
right yeah it's pretty can't even run
right where's he gonna go see they did
the full-on diversion emergency landing
thing and I'm like how many people on
your staff you can't just like [ __ ]
strap this guy into a chair and then
everybody gets to go where they're going
even the lady who got her boob grab and
then they can figure it out wait did you
guys overdo the Geo you talked to me
after I talked about this story there
was a story where this guy was farting
on a plane so much and he what yeah
farting did you guys do that one oh my
god and then to make an emergency you're
gonna have to stop farting farts gonna
no that's it landed I hope do we bring
the plane down we're bringing the point
we're bring it bring it down bring it
down he just starts all the way down
like that's how I imagined it going
rancid was that far dude like farts fart
did I like I'm done with that everyone's
doing the air that must be a nutty fart
dude everyone's farting on the plane you
know everyone is cuz pressure changes
yeah yeah yeah but because of that [ __ ]
I feel like nobody would even you
normally knows but because this guy's
[ __ ] with nuts you ever sat behind
someone that just won't stop farting mmm
that happen every once and recently and
I just like I had the air and all just
like oh my god you smell that bad right
in front of me too I'm like they're like
miss please we back in titties like this
or your eyes are bloodshot
dude I was on a plane with a guy man
cat next to me I was going we were going
la to Florida and the guy the guy next
to me he smelled like a gymnasium like
just total Bo and he's right to my right
and do it the whole [ __ ] would have
to leave or die
two options at that point he starts
praying and wish like Bart I could do
this you know and it'll go away
eventually bo will stay throughout that
whole [ __ ] flight yeah I know it's
just got used to it who knows yeah
oh my god you know in those situations I
feel like you can just like cover your
nose and like don't break eye contact
with them like yeah I know what you did
what does it help because I don't know
some people have no shame at all they
don't even care before they get on the
plane that's the guy that for it's what
I shower like a [ __ ]
at least he doesn't smell like beer the
reverse when they put on too much
cologne that's the worst - I guess there
was a guy like that - you know like in
flights though they tell you that you
shouldn't put on too much cologne go
yeah it's like a rule like you can't
wear too much cologne oh don't do that I
think I think so I forgot where I was
reading it but it's like a pamphlet
things like you shouldn't work I think
you're talking about when you're getting
hired guys you put on too much come on
don't know what too much cologne is it's
just walk into it I just got yeah but
see did but some guys they go like okay
why I know I need to do less so I'll
just do for sports today and it's like
you exactly ever since that farting dude
like I have to always travel with the
mask on with the reason one when I fall
asleep in public I fall asleep with my
mouth wide open because people just
sometimes they sink so I'm like I can't
do this yeah fall asleep my mouth open
Java vlog though I actually one time I
was boarding a plane and there was a
kind of like dirty hippie looking dude
with a guitar he was like three people
ahead of me I could smell him it was so
bad and when he got up to the line we're
like they check to make sure you have
your shoes off and so like that they
pulled him aside and he could not board
the plane but I it smelled so bad yeah
well but I mean penny they new
passengers would have complained so yeah
they can literally pull you it's amazing
I love that [ __ ] people do you have a
guitar in your hand
I can already I can already smell you
but by the way if you could afford a
plane ticket you could also afford to
wash yourself yeah yeah yeah yes yes I'm
pulling the plane over bro
[Music]
[Music]